it says a lot about Molly Russell's
story that her name has made its way to
the boardrooms of some of the world's
most wealthy and Powerful tech companies
but what impact has it had
platforms say child restrictions are
better graphic content prohibited and
human oversight improved
a basis so
dead it's controlled by computer
algorithms designed to keep users glued
to their apps the longer they can keep
you in there the better and the more
engaged and it comes with a lot of
pitfalls because if I'm very angry and I
say I hate this thing I'm seeing it's
still engagement I'm still writing
comments and clicking and spending my
time there and that's what we end up
having a lot contents that makes people
very engaged whether it's for good or
bad and five years on from Molly's death
his social media really safer
we found that anyone using Instagram for
example when you enter the first few
harmless words of a hashtag we'll find
the app autofills search responses
including one relating to a method of
suicide and when you click on that it
takes you to content relating to that
method including an image viewed and
saved by Molly Russell and admitted as
evidence at her inquest
since we alerted them Instagram has now
taken down this post and the search
recommendation but the campaigners it
demonstrates social media remains
dangerous for children until regulated
by law it was pushed it was recommended
it was it was algorithmically charged
into Molly's life so she went down a
rabbit hole and couldn't clamber out
that is a design products have to change
no more sorries no more apologies
we need them to act at now and we need
the power to ensure that they do
the widest significance of this inquest
asked Francis Haugen a former Facebook
data scientist who blew the whistle in
the U.S on how the company now called
meta put profits ahead of child safety
but there is a deep mythology inside of
Facebook that they produce that was the
bad you know there might be a few tragic
cases there's so much value from
connecting people that you know they can
they don't they can sleep well tonight I
wish they would look at these deaths and
treat them as preventable there's no
reason they don't have to be happening
at least at the numbers that we're
seeing and I wish they would take some
responsibility and act nearly every
other product we give our children must
be designed with their safety in mind if
Molly Russell's story tells us anything
it's that an algorithm is no different
social media no special case
Tom Clark Sky News